[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute zeige ich euch in meinem video wie
man eine richtig leckeres barbecue sauce
macht auch kelis art ich mag barbecue
saucen eigentlich gar nicht mir sind die
oft zu rauchig und einfach bis nicht so
intensiv und auch zu künstlich aber
heute habe ich meine eigene soße gemacht
und die ich wirklich super lecker dass
sie noch nicht probiert
ja das wollte ich schon immer mal sagen
ja wirklich sollen halte ich die
barbecue sauce das highlight und die
beilage wir haben einfach dazu ein
hähnchen gemacht aus dem ofen und sie
ist kartoffeln pommes richtig länge und
beilage zu so sicher ja man sieht was
ist das ist weil die soße streit war zum
glück verschlossen guck mir zölibat und
die bank die soße kann man für alles
mögliche nehmen nicht nur für ein
hähnchen sondern auch bis paris oder als
grillsauce als sony für steak also ist
wirklich super lecker und man kann sie
auch abfüllen und wirklich ein halbes
jahre lagern also die geht ja nicht
kaputt weil ich nicht glaube dass den
halbes jahr erreicht also wir machen
schon mal eine größere menge und vor
allem ist was drin ist genau aber zuerst
einmal wenn ich etwas hinziehen
vorbereiten
ich habe hier mein hähnchen und zwar ist
es ein werner station das heißt einfach
dass es artgerechter aufwachsen darf mit
mehr platz im stall und so weiter und
hier habe ich jetzt ein bisschen
paprikapulver und zwar jeweils einen
teelöffel cayenne pulver und edel süßes
paprikapulver ein bisschen für die farbe
die habe ich olivenöl und salz pfeffer
kommt erst später dazu weil pfeffer im
backofen verbrennt jetzt vermisse ich
hier paprikapulver mit dem öl
da kommt jetzt noch salz dazu und damit
kann ich jetzt das hähnchen einreiben
und ich mache das jetzt erstmal mit
einem pinsel und danach kommt das
hähnchen in den block beutel und kann
dann darin etwas marinieren
[Musik]
in den beutel könnt ihr zum beispiel
auch geschnittene knoblauchzehe mit rein
legen dann nimmt es hin ziehen auch noch
ein bisschen knoblauch aroma an
und während das hähnchen jetzt im
kühlschrank ein bisschen mariniert
bereit ich jetzt die soße zu und zeigt
euch mal die zutaten die ich für meine
sally barbecue soße verwenden für die
barbecue sauce brauche ich zwei
knoblauchzehen 40 milliliter öl 300
gramm ketchup 100 gramm essig 100 gramm
braunem zucker 120 gramm honig 60 gramm
butter soßen 60 gramm sind
hier habe ich etwas chili und hier habe
ich heuer salz ich nehme jetzt zuerst
die knoblauchzehen und die werden fein
gewürfelt
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich das öl nehmen und hier in
einem topf erhitzen und die
knoblauchzehen kurz darin anbraten
[Musik]
und die knoblauchzehen berate ich jetzt
nur kurz mit dass sie ganz lecker
dürften also immer der nase nach
jetzt gebe ich den zucker mit dazu und
den honig man kann das ganze ein
bisschen karamellisieren
ich glaube der murat wird jetzt sagen
dass sich der honig von glücklichen
wählen
[Musik]
einfach nur kurzfilm bis das ganze schön
kocht und jetzt kommen noch die übrigen
zutaten dazu also essig dann ketchup da
achtet immer darauf dass es ein ketzer
bisher nicht so süß ist weil wir auch
zucker und honig noch drin haben dann
die blumenmuster chance die man so
komisch ausspricht sind da könnte die
songs sind wurde auch in 15 verbänden
und jetzt kommt die wichtigste zutat das
ist missbrauch salz und es gibt im
ganzen diese traurige aroma und will ihn
jetzt alles schön verrühren und dann
etwa für zehn minuten leicht köcheln
lassen
[Musik]
die soße sitzt bereit das happiness
mariniert und jetzt kommt in den
backofen
natürlich ohne gefrierbeutel und zwar
habe ich jetzt hier unten ein backblech
darf alles drauf trocken das kann man
nämlich einfacher machen einen ganzen
backofen jetzt nämlich das hähnchen
heraus die marinade noch aufheben und
den knoblauch jetzt entfernen der wird
nämlich sowieso verbrennen
ich arbeite jetzt mit einem braten
thermometer das hat hier drei sensoren
und zwar deswegen weil es fleisch
einfach etwas später gar und auch heiß
wird als zum beispiel der knochen oder
auch der hohlraum und da hat sie drei
sensoren und die messen sind einfach
ganz genau die innere kerntemperatur und
wenn alle drei sensoren 85 grad erreicht
haben ist das hähnchen perfekt falls ihr
kainz habt könnt ihr ganz normal das
hähnchen auf europakurs lägen bei 170
grad ober unterhitze für etwa eine
stunde gaben dann müsste es auch die
perfekte temperatur erreicht haben
[Musik]
wer ist bestreichen einfach noch mal mit
der marinade also mit dem olivenöl
paprika gemischt und dann darfst dem
ofen garen
[Musik]
ich kann jetzt bei mir einfach direkt
auf die heizung hat ober unterhitze
wählen
170 grad und hier kann ich jetzt die
kerntemperatur einstellen und bei
hähnchen 85 grad dann ist es perfekt
durch um nicht trocken und dann schaltet
der ofen ganz von alleine aus wenn ich
die perfekte temperatur erreicht habe
aber ansonsten einfach eine stunde
die pfarrer fähnchen die perfekte
temperatur erreicht und zählt auch
wirklich sehr lecker aus kann das
thermometer raus vorsicht race und jetzt
bestreite ich es einfach mal mit dem
software hier unten ist ein glänzender
schön und ich hab's auch einmal während
der backzeit noch mit soße bestrichen
und sollte es richtig lecker
[Musik]
solch der sonnen beinchen geben bewusst
ist manchmal an brust und man jemanden
keule mögen deutsch sprach schwerter
zunächst test warst du kriegst und da
gibt es ja auch noch leute die sagen ein
richtiges hähnchen muss zitiert sein
ja das tut mir ja mal ausprobieren der
meinung ich ja auch ich habe das gefühl
hast ja woran merkst dass ich merkte es
sei nicht einfach zu billig ok
nachdem sega und dem gegen das bein
ausgerissen hat ja bis jetzt mal
probieren hatte aber so viel spreche ich
drauf machen müssen
glaub mir doch okay und er weiß noch
nicht wie gut das ist also hier sind
noch nicht probiert ich bin jetzt eher
straff gekommen ja und hier sind die
süßkartoffel comments der schutz
fingerfood daher ist auch mit den
fingern
der baustellen liegen mir kollegen hallo
heute geht's mir bald hier also jetzt
probiert es probiert jetzt aus wie
sowohl links diese wolfsrudel emotions
gelegt der auftrag bereits so viel wie
jetzt
[Gelächter]
richtig cool
das tolle ist dass sie nicht süß
schmeckt ja obwohl natürlich viel zucker
und honig drin ist aber durch des raubs
als bekommt ihn richtig tolles rauchiges
aroma ohne zu große werden wohl ohne zu
rauchen auf jeden fall also ich finde
das rezept mega lecker probiert auf
jeden fall mal diese konstellation aus
und die barbecue sauce die ist wirklich
sehr lange haltbar einfach ganz heiß
noch in die flaschen füllen verschließen
auf den kopf stellen
dann zieht zwar um und ich wirklich gut
haltbar ist aber nicht ganz tolle
geschenkidee aus der küche und ich
wünsche euch viel spaß beim nachmachen
hier noch einen guten tipp du kleiner
skeptiker mehr spielen sich st wieso
machst du barbecue sauce ich mache doch
kräuter hähnchen ja aber heute ging soll
die brücke soll also bis zum nächsten
mal eine beilage des hähnchen ich auch
super
[Gelächter]
ja
[Musik]